imagine if charles darwin had had access
to a spaceship
to travel around our galaxy and collect
samples what would such an intergalactic
beagle
accomplish
that's what parakertian mountains
fascinating new book the zoologist guide
to the galaxy reveals
one of the most brilliant zoologists of
our time
takes us on a journey through our galaxy
and what it means to be conscious to be
a life form
and the prospects for what that will
teach us about life on earth he's a
delightful individual and you're going
to love this book it's the book that
darwin wished he could have written way
back in the early 1800s when he first
set sail aboard the hms beagle come
along with a modern-day darwin as we
explore the galaxy and all the wonderful
creatures that may await us come along
let's go into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
and it is a great pleasure to have on
kirschenbaum of cambridge university all
the way across the pond and here we have
uh some simulated british weather
because it's actually not 72 degrees and
sunny in san diego today it's pouring
and about 55 degrees so winter is
finally here in in early march uh how
are you eric it's great yeah we're doing
great here maybe winter's not even close
to being over actually
what can you do it's a great treat to
have you on the podcast you're a fan
favorite i wanted to have you on for
years and now on the occasion of the
paperback book uh launch of the
zoologist guide to the galaxy i thought
it was an opportune time to chat with
you and i think this book dovetails
nicely with some themes that are
percolating in the in the metaverse in
the in the
universe of ideas and the zeitgeist
however you want to call it about alien
life and what it might be like and what
it might teach us about life on earth uh
but before we do that um we always like
to do the thing you're never supposed to
do
as a reader but what else can you do you
don't have any you talk a lot in the
book about game theory well how how do
you apprise whether you should read this
book or watch a cat video um and so i
want to ask you and we're going to play
my favorite game and it's called
judging books by their covers
[Music]
uh what is the uh genesis uh if you will
to use a very loaded phrase of with with
good reason as you'll see what is
genesis of the title of the subtitle and
the cover art of your wonderful new book
yeah well it's it's it is interesting
because it's a it's an unusual book you
don't see a lot of books that that
combine questions like life in the
universe with life on earth so um it
wasn't a particularly easy sell so a lot
of a lot of publishers were reluctant to
go anywhere near a scientific
examination of of extraterrestrial life
and and and really i i actually when i
first conceived the book i really wanted
to write a book more about about life on
earth and maybe with a little bit of of
of aliens here and there just to just to
give a nice comparison and um
and
most publishers were like you know what
ditch the aliens
write a book about animals ditchy aliens
and then my i'm very lucky that the
publisher i ended up with they said well
we like the idea but can you beef up the
aliens a bit um and have more aliens in
there um so that's that is really why it
got the emphasis um the emphasis that it
did but it's it's a blend of those two
questions and that's where the subtitle
fits in really nicely because
this is a book about
the laws governing alien uh the the
nature of alien life
but it's a book about the laws governing
life
and therefore it's a book about us it's
a book about life on earth it's a book
about the diversity of life or not where
it came from um and and and and where we
came from and and what our nature is so
so in in
it really is that that blend between
between the two and and i i think that
worked out nicely i like that
it was very reminiscent you know not to
to you know damn it with high praise but
it reminded me of you know what i know
about darwin's you know voyage of the
beagle it was very reminiscent of this
you know kind of journey obviously of
sort of this hero's journey
that that darwin took but you take more
of an intellectual rather than you know
you're not actually journeying you know
spoiler alert to other other parts of
the galaxy yet um
but uh but speaking of beagles it looks
like you're joined by some life forms in
the background i don't believe they're
beagles but uh
tell us about your your uh collaborators
there
well um
if you're referring to my dog darwin
he's he's lying on the floor there and
and groaning a little bit he's 15 years
old so uh so uh he's entitled to groan
and he's entitled to sleep as well
yes most teenage
teenage boys will will take you up on
that offer um so in that spirit you know
this this magical kind of journey that
you take us along
and i'm not accompanied by any living
forms but i did bring a galaxy you can
see it in the back over there there's a
the whirlpool galaxy m51 uh which is a
coalescing galaxy and i wanted to you
know kind of really start with with a um
with a quote that you mentioned in the
book uh from the namesake of the
organization that i'm pleased to be
co-director of which is the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination here
at uc san diego and you quote sir arthur
and you say nowhere in space will we
rest our eyes upon the familiar shapes
of trees and plants or any of the
animals that share our world whatsoever
life we meet we'll be as strange and
alien as the nightmare creatures of the
ocean abyss or of the insect empire
whose horrors are normally hidden from
us by their microscopic scales um
what what about that quote really
resonates with you is it is it the you
know kind of disabuse of this notion
that we're going to meet you know
entities with just bigger foreheads than
us and and big eyes and gray skin what
what what about that quote resonates
with you
well it resonates with me for for
its its errors as well as it is for its
uh for its insight and
you know if you look at the history of
humans thinking about life on other
planets we've gone through all these
phases we've gone through phases of um
being convinced that that that other
other worlds have human-like creatures
on them and and through to this to a
great deal of skepticism um and really
until the discovery of exoplanets uh 20
years ago
skepticism dominated
the idea of what we might know about
about life on other planets and in that
in that period in that period between
certainty that there were angels on
other worlds and
a discovery that there might actually be
life on that we can discover on other
planets
a lot of a lot of poor ideas came into
uh consideration about of of of alien
life and and the one that i like the
best because i think it's a fantastic
book in every respect other than than
its um
consideration of biology was fred
hoyle's the black clouds one of my
favorite science fiction uh books and
it's really a tremendous read
um but it really typifies this idea that
whatever's out there has got to be so
completely different so completely alien
that we can't know anything about it and
that's just not true i mean that arises
out of a lack of understanding of what
life is and where life comes from and
and the case that i make and and i hope
i make it convincingly is that there are
rules there are constraints there are
laws um there are things that that mean
that
while uh we may not see trees like trees
on earth
but trees of some sort there will
probably be so i think i think that that
quote by arthur c clarke is nice because
it it it
simultaneously
gives the idea that
don't let's think that that we're going
to have alien humans with with large
foreheads
but at the other time it it it just goes
too far we've got to pull back a bit and
understand that life is governed by
rules
do you think that um along those lines
that because there's sort of this
fixation that either aliens will be just
like us in some sense you know have five
kind of vast appendages or whatever uh
uh or you know we'll have some sort of
symmetry properties or will be
macroscopic you know on the kind of
midway point between the planck scale
and the size of the universe in some
sense um do you think that you know with
me it resonates with this um uh quote
from the right stuff uh the book by
thomas wolf about the astronaut program
and there was a quote in there um you
know that they said we can't get money
unless they're
astronauts on these you know i mean
obviously humans could do anything that
john glenn did you know go up in a rock
and come back down and dogs did that but
their quote was no buck no buck rogers
no bucks
or maybe it was the other way around but
but the point being that you had a sort
of appeal of pandering somewhat to the
human interest aspect of things and i
think especially with this resurgence of
interest and alien you know craft coming
here i mean what could be more like we
are than some alien you know flying
discs that yeah maybe they use different
propulsion that we don't understand but
they're using crafts about the size of
our airplanes and the inhabitants must
be about the same size as us um do you
think that that's you know fundamentally
an anthropomorphic or anthropocentric
um vantage point that the in
contradistinction to the alien insects
of clark that there's a whole other camp
that says no they must be like us and
and and kind of in order to appeal to
our desire and maybe funding and so
forth
well
there's
i think there are many things that are
driving
public perception of what
alien life
might be like and look
right on at the beginning we've got to
put on the table any alien life that we
discover in the next 50 years is going
to be microbial or or the equivalent you
know we're not we're not genuinely i
don't think that i will ever get the
chance to you know study alien animals
and in the way that i study animals on
earth so so i think that that's a really
a long way off but in terms of the
public perception of what aliens are
like um
you know
it's been driven a lot by our fear of
humans
if you think about the flying saucers
and the alien invasions and you know
this this is all cold war stuff this is
all
um this is all
appealing to it to a public narrative
that has little to do
with life on other planets and and so
it's best just to discard that i think i
mean it's it's one of the reasons that i
don't subscribe to the whole the whole
ufo idea is apart from any um any sort
of rational and scientific reasons i i
just feel that it's
that it seems to be a throwback to uh to
to the conflict between the united
states and the soviet union and and it's
unconvincing to me i'm much more
interested
in the fundamental scientific rules that
might actually give us some idea about
about what alien life forms might be
like
you talk about the microbial probability
just now and it made me think of you
know something that i've got on the
record about
and maybe a little bit controversial but
i claim you know tomorrow we wake up and
you know let's do a good dunkin
experiment we wake up and you know so my
colleagues here i've got a colleague you
know professor shelly wright she does
optical study she does but let's just
say one of her colleagues and or her
whatever they discover you know some
byproduct of microbial life or maybe
this um you know this meteorite that
landed in antarctica
and where i've spent uh two winters or
two summers i guess it was my son their
summer my winter um you know they oh it
actually is a microbial respiratory
byproduct okay um i claim that
excitement will last for a week um and
and
uh but almost no more and i'm wondering
like what do you think would be the
reaction because i think we have already
seen what happened i mean the the
meteorite that fell in the allen hills
has never conclusively been falsified to
not contain alien remnants it was
announced by president bill clinton on
the white house front lawn in 1997 i
believe 96 and uh it's never been
refuted so we already kind of have the
answer to this g-dunkin experiment but
what do you think do you think that it
would fundamentally change our
perspective of our place in hu and
as a species in the in the galaxy and in
the universe
i i totally agree with you i think i
think it wouldn't i don't think that the
discovery of microbial alien life will
will hold the public imagination for for
very long
but it doesn't need to it doesn't need
to you know it needs to it it is a
scientific discovery and not a not a pr
discovery um the goal is not to to
create a media circus the goal is to
find out what's going on what's going on
in the universe and
in the long term of course it will be
hugely it will be hugely important look
we're dealing at the moment with
huge existential threats to to humanity
we need to deal with our with our
climate threat
discovering uh microbes in a in another
solar system and it's not going to
change that and it's not going to make
us um come together and say well oh we
have to save life on this planet because
there's life on other planets something
like that but
it's a fundamental shift in our science
it's a fundamental shift in our
understanding of science i
am not a historian but i would be very
surprised if when copernicus declared
that the earth goes around the sun that
people were running around in the
streets screaming and and you know
waving their arms about i think it's
unlikely but it's still it's still
generated a shift in the way that
science is done and the way that we
understand the the our observations
absolutely yeah that that is uh that is
true and you make this beautiful
statement you know that we are the first
generation that cannot in human history
that cannot say that they're you know
that earth is unique among the types of
planets that earth is the earth-like
planet uh there's not just one
earth-like planet and and similarly it
made me think back to yeah i mean back
when giordano bruno uh you know was
burned at the stake for claiming that
stars were other sons uh he couldn't
claim that you know he couldn't get away
with that um
but uh but we're living in a completely
new paradigm because of the discoveries
of things like kepler and others and and
i want to push back with respect uh not
on you but but on kind of this this
feeling in the community of which you
are one of the foremost kind of
expositors which is that um you know
life is abundant in the universe and
that if it's not it's kind of a waste of
space and i hear this a lot from my
religious friends uh who will say you
know if there is no god uh then you know
life is ultimately unjust and the
universe is unjust not because why did
the good um get punished and the wicked
thrive and and you know theodicy the
basic question of theater i think
there's a theodesic component to al you
know another they have to exist because
there's so much space and again you know
just hearkening from my experience in
antarctica i saw like six penguins you
know the whole time i've been there i
spent two months there almost
six penguins in my whole life and i
couldn't get close enough to one to
bring it home from one of my kids but
uh i would probably be shot on sight but
you know it's a capacious continent you
know it's one seventh of all the
continents on earth and yet there's
almost no you know animal life there
besides you know some some scua birds
and a couple of sea lions and uh but on
the continent itself almost nothing it's
completely devoid of life
even my even microbial life is hard to
find but a lot of the people in the
extraterrestrial life community
claim that discoveries like kepler
those by kepler satellite those by um
researchers on extremophiles another
famous you know kind of um
event was about seven years ago the
discovery of this arsenic life you'll
recall that in um in mono lake here in
in california beautiful place and that
turned out to be unverifiable and yet it
was a press release it was a accepted
paper in science uh and so forth so
a lot of the research that i hear and i
get criticism from my colleagues why are
you setting institute people why are you
spending money researching extremophiles
and researching you know uh sociological
language as you talk about in the book a
lot um is that not putting you know the
the car far far ahead of the alien horse
or
i mean we have no evidence i think and
you say this in the book it's not really
a criticism of the book but there's no
evidence for life elsewhere so like
talking about second order things like
their culture and society what do you
say to somebody who criticizes that as
being so far in advance
of what um you know what is justified by
the evidence
well the the
the appeal of thinking about aliens
stimulates
important discussions about life
if we want to know if we're asking so
you ask
quite rightly the question why does why
should all the space be filled
well
why should this space be filled comes
down to some very clear scientific
questions that we can ask how likely
is a biogenesis how likely is life to
arise from non-life if it's very likely
to arise
then the answer to your question is yes
the space will be filled
if it's very unlikely to arise then then
then perhaps not but these are these are
questions that that can be addressed
scientifically so so if we didn't
think about alien life we might not be
asking those questions at all
now when it comes to the kinds of
questions that i ask which may seem even
further into the future about about
societies about language and and what
kind of language would aliens have
you're quite right that these are not
testable hypotheses
but they're the opportunity to ask
important questions about the
constraints on biological life
and they then have implications for us
on earth which is hence the subtitle of
the book right what what it tells about
ourselves sometimes you cannot think
about yourself
without thinking about
where your place is in in in the greater
scheme of things so as i said i do not
believe i will ever
get to to to watch alien animals and and
you know unless unless we're really
lucky i mean what i'm praying for is
that is that that some alien
civilization somewhere has this david
attenborough uh sort of equivalent and
they're beaming their nature
documentaries to us that's possibility
but no i don't i don't seriously hold
out hope for seeing alien animals but by
thinking about what they would be like
if they do exist
tells us a great deal about animal life
on earth and how that arise arose and
and and where it's going yeah
so um along those themes you know again
i i i this book is phenomenal in that it
is evocative of this great you know
magnificent work by darwin and the white
of the beagle and and other and other
works um and uh speaking of your dog
darwin seems pretty pretty content over
there um what is it about zoologists you
guys um yeah i'm an astronomer so i'm on
the a side of the alphabet you're a z a
zoologist what is it about that um
profession i mean you've studied
everything from coral to wolves um what
made you pivot to aliens
why that um
very dynamic pivot
yep well um my field is animal
communication so that's what i what i
what i research and
um i
one of the things that i do uh is
looking at where information is in
animal calls so
broadly speaking you could ask what do
they mean
but we need to drill down and and define
that a little bit more rigorously so
let's let's talk very generally what
kind of information exists in an animal
called when a bird sings
what information is it putting into its
song when a wolf howls how much
information is there are they just
saying who they are or that they are
there or is there more information about
like it's time to go hunting or
something like that so that's that's
that's my field uh and that's quite an
algorithmic um
endeavor because we need to look at
statistical properties of of these calls
and and correlations between different
elements of the call and and so on
so i actually organized a uh
investigative workshop uh a number of
years ago uh on this topic on the topic
of information in in animal
vocalizations and one of the applicants
to take part um
was a man who you might know uh lawrence
doyle at the seti institute
and he works at seti institute and his
big thing is that
if we're ever going to if we ever
receive
communication from tech alien
technological civilizations and we want
to decode that um
the best our best bet for getting a
handle on how we might decode that is to
try and decode the communication of
animals
um so he said can i come to you to your
to your conference and he did and we had
a great time and we started talking we
started talking about
questions that are important questions
for zoologists
and independently important questions
for seti researchers like for instance
here's a sound
is it a language how do we know
right i mean we often say birds animals
they don't have a language only humans
have a language how do we know that you
know is there some sort of test we can
do
to see whether birdsong or dolphin
whistles are a language
and
it's a difficult question it's not clear
that there is such a test but if there
were such a test it would be a useful
one for seti scientists to have as well
when they start receiving signals from
from outer space so it kind of grew out
of that um that analogy of
is there information in this signal
whether it's a dolphin or whether it's
an alien
and you make a very convincing case
regarding language that language must
benefit first and foremost the sender of
the signal
uh and yet you seem to be very much at
the at the cornerstone you know of
what's called medi not meta um although
if mark zuckerberg wants to sponsor your
research your mind we're welcome uh
welcome him with open arms but um what
is medi why is that um you know a legit
i mean again this is
one of the world's most eminent
zoologists uh you know uh profession you
know
practiced by folks like richard dawkins
and other and you're talking about
messaging extraterrestrial intelligences
so talk to talk to our audience about
this and don't be afraid to be you know
super geeky we have the most erudite
tech savvy audience in the known
universe so talk about medi what is it
and how could that possibly benefit us
eric when there's at least some percent
chance as your fellow countrymen and and
uh university colleague stephen hawking
said even if it's like a point one
percent chance that they could be
malevolent could end our civilization
and only benefit the few boffins like
you and me so tell us eric what is medi
why does it interest the zoologist and
what about the risks
so metti as a concept is the idea that
that we should be sending messages to
extraterrestrial civilizations so we're
searching seti we're searching for
extraterrestrial intelligence but of
course if everyone is searching and no
one is is uh is sending then no one's
going to hear anything we could all be
standing around and just just not
knowing that the universe is full of
very shy civilizations um so there is a
there's a
there's an argument to be made that
maybe we should be sending signals this
is
by the way a um an intellectual argument
so no one's actually
these days no one is actually building
transmitters to to send things but there
is a valid question should we be sending
messages
and as you say there are people um who
say no this is too big a risk
we should keep our heads down and and
not let the aliens know that we're
around because they might come and eat
us so um
i think it's very worthwhile to debunk
that idea
and there's a couple of reasons for that
firstly i think it's a bad idea i i
think it's it's uh it's not a sound
argument uh it's not a sound argument
primarily because we've been
broadcasting radio signals into space
for a hundred years now and and anyone
who has anything like the technology to
come and and eat us um already knows
that we're here um so i think it's
spacious from the beginning in that
respect um
but also i think it's
unreasonable and
backward looking to think that aliens
are going to come and eat us
again it it it brings us back to our to
that period between the 1920s and the
1980s when when it was the cold war that
was that was the concern we were worried
about being invaded um now as a
physicist you know that
any technology that's capable of
transporting uh life forms from one star
system to another must be so advanced so
far ahead of us
that not only um will they already know
that we're here
but
if they have the kind of energy
resources to travel between the stars
they don't need to eat a few humans okay
i mean they really it it it just seems
like a projection of our own in our own
earthbound imperialism that we are
afraid of being invaded so so i think
it's
i think on both of those counts i think
it's a weak argument that we shouldn't
be sending messages but the reason that
i that i think it's an important
argument to have
is because we need to change the way
that we think about
what life in the universe must be like
if we continue to think
that
it's all about invading aliens who are
coming to who are coming to destroy us
then then that will tarnish our
scientific effort it will it will
tarnish our attempts to understand what
alien
life might be like and and and i think
it's important to put things on a more
solid footing they're not coming to eat
us
uh pertinent to your you know comment
that we've been sending out information
for
75 years or whatever did you ever hear
the joke about these archaeologists in
the middle east and they discover
different things and i'll tell it just
in case my audience hasn't heard it um
you know i'm a purveyor of relentless
purveyor of dad jokes but this isn't
quite a dad but anyway three
archaeologists are in uh sharing their
exploits one from jordan
comes up he pulls out this big uh you
know piece of copper like in a cable and
he goes look this proves jordanian
scientist
invented you know underground wireless
conduction of communication and morse
code uh this is evident clear evidence
of this thousands of years ago in amman
jordan then an egyptian archaeologist
she gets up and says no no we found this
funnel and it dates back you know a
thousand years earlier and uh and it's
evidence that we invented in egypt
um you know communication using antennas
because it's kind of like an antenna um
and then the israeli archaeologist gets
up and says we found this and they're
like
what did you find he said it's nothing
yes exactly we invented wireless
communication
so um
uh it's kind of a joke but yeah i mean
we have been sending out information but
it's you know it's kind of a
monopolar distribution very low um you
know targeting you know messaging the
specific star systems and and we have
sent out messages the pioneer disc you
know which had the recordings of the
brain waves of past guest andrew
uh on the podcast she's been on the
podcast before she recorded her brain
wave sent it on to the universe yeah the
likelihood of that being found is pretty
is pretty low too um but you know this
this notion that of of pure benefit um
is it true and i've always wondered
about this you know in terms of like
things that are done frivolously
besides the rock musicians that seem to
be pretty um pretty adept at
you know mate selection
or whatever you may say i want to keep
it g rated here uh but um you know what
is the purpose of music i mean it is is
sort of you know expending a lot of
energy a lot of effort um as a form of
communication it's very low bandwidth
you know if you have to listen to a
whole song to find out how this guy his
girlfriend dumped them and he got a new
pickup truck whatever uh what is the
purpose of a current perspective on the
evolutionary purpose of music
[Music]
well music is um
is
seems to be not restricted to to humans
um we know that i've got student at the
moment um vicki pham who's doing her her
studies on rhythmic behavior in
chimpanzees and how that might relate to
the evolution of of music in in humans
you know whether we whether we gain a a
direct benefit from from these
from generating complex rhythms um so so
there is uh
you know there are there are analogues
of music in in animals and birds being
the obvious example
but
you always have to remember that that
when we
take a a concept like music or or art um
or even or even social concepts like for
instance um
empathy and
and fairness a lot of people talk often
about how
there are many animals many primates who
who have a sense of fairness
um
you know these are
these are
behaviors that evolved to provide a
benefit for those
organisms and and um clearly birdsong
you know provides a benefit for the for
the male bird and it's impressing the
female bird or the male the male
challenger but they only really become
music
um
when placed in the context of human
society
so this something happened something
happened when you know half a million
years ago or a hundred thousand years
ago something happened
where human society was able to take all
of these all of these different
behaviors and turn them into cultural
phenomena
which is something slightly different
from from from what's happening in the
animal so so
while there are clear parallels and
clearly our music is is based and has
its origins
in in adaptive behaviors that are that
are very very beneficial for other
animals it does seem to be it turns into
something different
when it comes in
in into human society uh that but that
is a complex question and you know i can
answer that one i don't know the answer
and uh it kind of you know reminded me
uh you know a section of the book um
which which comes later but it's about
competition and and warfare and all
sorts of things um and uh i want to
cover that but um but it made me think
of you know what is the pr
throughout this book the main you know
kind of progenitor you know protagonist
is is you know evolution via natural
selection but i'm wondering if we can go
even deeper um you know than natural
selection because a lot of places start
off with natural selection once you turn
it on uh you know the the game is a foot
right um but um but i want to go deeper
and actually well before if you'll
permit me another joke um so you've
heard the question you know which came
first the chicken or the egg right
so one of my kids told me you know she
had an idea um you could find out which
comes first the chicken or the egg and
you just order a chicken on amazon and
an egg
and you see which comes from that okay
that you can use that feel free to use
that but i want to ask you this question
as you know one of the world's most
eminent zoologists um and thinkers about
these topics it's not clear to me that
you know natural selection is really the
starting point it seems like throughout
this book uh the resonant message to me
is that competition uh you know whether
it be for resources you know or mates
and maybe you know you could think kind
of blindly in the animal kingdom that
you know mates are a form of resource um
what would it um which comes first i
mean is it the recognition you know
obviously at the at the macro scale in
societies that there's fights for
resources we're witnessing one right now
in ukraine right uh but but tell me
is there a notion that something you
know is is a is a proto
evolutionary requirement that there be
competition i mean you could imagine
like certain civilization structures
maybe only artificial intelligence that
wouldn't be competitive so um is there
something more primal more primitive
than natural selection or am i totally
off base
not totally off base but it's and it's a
absolutely crucial point so
natural selection
requires
three things so there are three
necessary conditions for
natural selection to occur and there
needs to be some sort of heritable
information so passed on from one from
one organism to another um there needs
to be variation in the in the
characteristics of of those individuals
and there needs to be what we call
differential fitness some need to do
better than others
which in the most
part comes down to competition you can
imagine ways where it may not be
competitive but essentially that is
competition now these three
requirements of system any system um
for natural selection to occur are not
just necessary requirements they're also
sufficient requirements
which means that any system that does
happen
to have those three properties will
undergo natural selection
whether it's artificial whether it's
artificial intelligence whether it's
internet memes whether it's religion
whether whatever it is
if it's got those three properties then
it then it will undergo natural
selection so
the competition is inherently a part of
natural selection it's not that one came
first or or the other came after it's
that if
there are organisms which could
reproduce more effectively than other
organisms then you see natural selection
then you see natural selection taking
place
but the
other point about this when you talk
about chickens and eggs and and what
came first then how did it all start and
and things like that is
that you know even the most simple life
is unbelievably complex the mo the most
simple life that we know of is far far
more complex than anything that we could
build
and
and
we presume that the first
entities
that that underwent natural selection
were not alive but they were chemicals
so
there was a phase most likely when
chemical molecules themselves were
undergoing natural selection and that
was really where life began even though
it's not alive in in any sense that that
we would think of it today but it needed
that
differential fitness it needed some
molecules to reproduce more reliably and
more effectively than other molecules
and only then could natural selection
take over and and and uh and begin to to
lead to the diversity of life we have
now um no it's a lovely way to look at
it uh and what's again i'm sorry to keep
you know just praising you and beating
over the head with this uh but you are
one of the rare authors that do
something that i love to do on this
channel which is to debate with love and
basically to steal man your opponent's
ideas and not shy away and just beat
them over the head with strawman
and so forth so one of the things i came
away almost convinced to become a
lamarchian ark i'm sorry to tell you
that but you're so confused you're so
convincing uh about the kind of
aesthetic appeal of lamarck's uh
perspective in contrast to darwin first
for my uh listeners that need to buy the
book need to listen to the book um
can you tell uh can you explain a little
bit about this um contrast between these
two competing approaches why darwin won
and what still appeals
to you and now to me because you made me
a convert uh uh sad to say about
lamarchianism
so um evolution by natural selection is
horribly inefficient it's incredibly
inefficient right it's all down to which
of the which of the babies um get eaten
and which ones don't get eaten and and
you end up having to have a lot of
babies and and a lot of them get eaten
and
it's
evolution by natural selection seems to
be a a fairly effective way of
optimizing
various characteristics but it's by no
means efficient
um
and
that
raises the question perhaps there's a
more efficient
method a more efficient uh algorithm
that could out compete natural selection
um and perhaps would then actually take
over as a mechanism of of of increasing
complexity in in
in the the world of in the living world
and the one that that people talk about
is this idea which you can sort of
broadly talk about as lamarckian but the
idea that
experiences during your lifetime can be
transmitted to your offspring
so if um i as a
as a mother antelope recognize that a
lion is coming to get me and run away
and i escape from the lion it would be
much more efficient for my babies to
know that when they were born
um classic way that natural selection
works is my babies are born they don't
know about about lions or not about
lions and and half of them get eaten and
but surely it's much better if they
would know from the fact that i escaped
from a lion and that they should run
away from lions as well
and that idea that the experiences you
go through in your lifetime can be
passed on to your offspring um
should in theory perhaps
lead to faster evolution
but it doesn't seem to occur in the
natural world we don't see it now is
that because we only have one example of
life and perhaps there are planets out
there and and some of them have
darwinian evolution and some of them
have la market in evolution or is there
a reason why on earth we don't see this
kind of
this kind of phenomenon and
we don't know we don't know the answer
to that we can do a lot of mathematical
simulations which we do um and they kind
of give us a clue
that
it may be that lamarckian
evolution is somewhat um
capricious
and it may be a little bit less stable
because if you're always changing you
know your offspring are always um
taking the latest fad the latest fashion
um then they may in the long run um be
at a disadvantage um
and
we don't know the answer but but it ties
in really nicely to
the one place where we know that
lamarckian uh evolution does occur and
that's in human culture
so we know we can pass our life
experiences onto our offspring we do it
every day uh we do it by by reading them
bedtime stories and we and and uh
sending them to school so so there's a
good example of um
lifetime experiences being passed on to
offspring and look at the pace of
progress of human society it's been
phenomenal it's been exceptional
of course it may also end in the
extinction of mankind and i i think that
is a really nice illustration of how
just because something may be more
efficient it doesn't actually make it
necessarily more effective um and that
could be in fact a disadvantage of of
lamarcianism or it could be more you
know too efficient by half or something
and and therefore lead to you know this
notion of this great filter i i i wonder
are you familiar with that concept the
great filter and what's your perspective
uh first again for my audience that
might not be familiar uh what is the
great filter and then what might the
implications be if we are past it
through it in the middle of it
yeah
well the the this harks back to the
question of why haven't we heard
anything from any any aliens i mean
surely if there are alien civilizations
out there and they really are as
advanced as
they might be then they'd be everywhere
you know you'd see the spaceships flying
through the sky all the time and and
they'd be visiting us all the time
openly not not uh not just in in you
know the back waters of some um some
farmland somewhere but we don't see that
so so the question is why not and there
are many possible answers and many uh
answers explanations have been proposed
one is that um yes there's life all over
the universe uh yes there's complex life
all over the universe but as soon as
complex life becomes
technologically advanced it destroys
itself
and
although we don't have
any examples except for for one it's
certainly looking pretty much that way i
mean we're not doing a good job
of ensuring the the future of humanity
and if that is the case that that
technological advancement just comes so
quickly
that
a civilization is not ready for it and
not prepared to deal with the problems
and then they may just drive themselves
extinct um
is that likely
i would say it's one of the better
explanations for why we don't see
many alien civilizations i i think it it
certainly is this is the answer for me
fermi paradox yes yeah yeah so so it's
it's quite compelling um however there
is also the argument that if you do
manage to get through this great filter
so if you if we were somehow to stop our
uh climate change and to and to stop war
and to and to solve all the problems of
of humanity then essentially you become
unlimited
in your in your lifespan you know you
could a civilization like that could
exist for billions of years um
so it doesn't really solve the the fermi
paradox in that sense because surely
there'd be one or two that managed to
get through the great filter and then
where are they um but
yeah this is this is a uh an
intellectual question without a great
deal of data uh on which to base it i'm
afraid
and as an outsider um for the field of
astrophysics we're gonna pivot to next
uh and i'm sorry i wasn't showing my
galaxy before can you see the galaxy now
okay that's the whirlpool galaxy uh i
was uh i'm too too clever again by half
because i have two cameras and i
probably only need half of one camera
but um
the drake equation it kind of uh lays
out an astronomical terms a framework by
which one could predict a number of uh
intelligent species that could inhabit
the the galaxy and some have even
extended it further
my large problem with it is that
it's it's something that my students do
all the time which is that they they
quote a number you know newton's uh
gravitational constant uh you know and
they'll get the number right the average
the mean value correct but they won't do
any error analysis so it's like me
saying you know your dog you know darwin
weighs less than 10 000 kilograms okay
it's it's it's accurate it's not precise
um so the problem i have is that there's
uh very little attention paid to the
estimation of errors and we did hear
from uh of my friend christopher
consoles who's a professor in the uk a
very powerful professor because he
actually is the editor for app j that's
just the main journal or was uh in my
anyway he's a he's a friend um but you
know he did a prediction and he came up
with this number of you know there are
36 civilizations in the universe in the
galaxy and everyone's like why couldn't
you add six more so it could be 42. uh
but uh but the point being you know he
had assigned some likelihood to that and
it was a well-done presentation
controversial too but as an outsider how
do you look at that is there a um
zoologist drake equation we can make the
kirchenbaum
equation you know name it after you
maybe uh here's your opportunity
well
i agree with you i agree with you
entirely about about the drake equation
but to be fair people do um
do attempt to address those so a
colleague of mine for instance
uses probability distributions instead
of values so
rather than saying you know there are
this
planets habitable planets in the galaxy
say there's a distribution when with the
mean and a certain and a certain
variance so you can you can do that but
but
really i don't think the drake equation
was ever intended to give a number
no it was only ever a an illustration
of um of how there there these multiple
multiple constraints on on on the
evolution of life um
is there an equivalent is there a
zoological
equivalent um
i think that
the other
to answer that i'd say the other problem
with the drake equation is that it has a
single output a number of number of
civilizations um
whereas
if we're looking at extraterrestrial
life there's going to be a diversity of
extra whatever happens is going to be
diversity of extraterrestrial life i
mean assuming there's any there's not
none there will be a diversity so
much more interesting than how many
uh inhabited planets there are is what's
the diversity of different types of life
in in in the galaxy or in the in the
universe so if there were a zoological
drake equation uh it would tell it
wouldn't have a single output how many
it would it would tell you more about um
the different how many different kinds
of um
niches might be might be exploited you
know other are there um
are release or life pretty much the same
um or is it is it so diverse in the in
the kinds of uh kinds of habitats that
that it that it inhabits that it that it
must be very different you know are
there a lot of people have have um
have
speculated without really very good
basis that dna may be a universal
a universal molecule of heritable
information
is that true are there hundreds of
different kinds of molecules of
heritable information that's really the
sort of thing i think that i would be
more interested in rather than just
rather than just counting
very good um so i want to pivot to
astronomical topics so there's a fair
number of my uh audience members who are
astronomically inclined um some of my
best friends are astronomers um so i
want to first ask a question you brought
up uh sir fred hoyle
who's really a hero to many of us in the
field of astronomy controversial figure
as you know um
and i actually had on you might be
interested to know giant narlikar who
was his phd student at uh at cambridge
many years ago but uh you know sir fred
sadly is no longer with us but uh but
giant very much is in puna india and i
talked to him and his his wonderful wife
is a mathematician and we talked a lot
about you know these theories that don't
really um
ever go out of favor and one of them is
the steady state theory that he was an
exponent of and still is despite all the
evidence you know uh supporting at least
some version of an event uh creation or
initiation event um when the universe
was much different than it is now
and they keep adding on you know sort of
epicycles in some ways but there's many
reasons and there are many alternatives
to the singularity-based driven
narrative of the big bang by eminent you
know cosmologists such as past guest uh
sir roger penrose uh on the show and i
want to ask you um one of fred hoyle's
you know signature lines he has he was a
master of the of the mo zeus of the bon
mao
uh and one of his ideas was this idea of
panspermia which is one of these things
that sounds
sounds uh x-rated but it's really not um
and i want to ask you first to define
panspermia
what it really means and correct me if
i'm wrong that he was either the
coiner of that term or at least an
exponent of it uh and then i want to
pivot to from that to
why i think it provides some ev and a
bayesian
confidence interval perspective evidence
against the existence of life in the
universe other than earth but let's
start with that penspermia did hoyle
create that what does it mean and and um
what is its relevance in in the current
context
well
at the moment it's it's a it's an
interesting
topic that people do take take seriously
not in exactly the way that that fred
hoyle formulated it which was quite um
outlandish i would say um but the idea
that uh in some way
life is transferred between between
celestial bodies i think there's very
little doubt about that you know um the
simulation i
read the paper the simulations that the
asteroid that killed the dinosaurs right
ejected so much uh material from earth
um
that some of it will have landed on the
moons of jupiter and saturn already and
if microbes could have survived that 60
million year journey then we may get
there and find there's there's earth
life on on on these these planets it's
it's very reasonable and in that sense
in in terms of of um
life spreading between celestial bodies
in a single solar system um
i think it's i think it's a plausible
it's a plausible hypothesis of course it
doesn't answer any questions
about
the origin of life it doesn't answer any
questions about how life arose is just
kicking the can down the road a little
bit
more problematic of course
is a question of of directed panspermia
which is the intentional
seeding
of planets with with life which
presupposes a technological civilization
that is capable of of of sending uh
sending biological material between
between solar systems and
and um although i do you know play about
with that idea in the book a little bit
because there are some interesting um
some very interesting
questions that that that it that it um
it raises um
but i think if if that were the case
then
then
you know we're talking about a
post-filter civilization so
where are they why why aren't they here
so yeah i mean pertinent to that i've um
i've gone to chick-fil-a i've
taken my submersible vessel down uh some
20 kilometers and no i haven't done that
but but here's a chunk of a fragment i
actually have a chunk of um of the
planet mars uh which i got delivered via
the united postal service here in
america but um you can buy them you can
buy fragments you know a gram or two uh
which is uh more than i have but um but
then you're touching like a piece of
another planet and it's it's known to
have the same chemical composition the
crustal analysis my geology friends tell
me it's identical um so again to push
back like if i told you that there is
this process
um of interchange of material and we
exchange material with with as you said
you know definitely some material is
ejected into space from chick-fil-a and
from the you know the tk event and the
create end of the cretaceous or jurassic
period um but um but why wouldn't that
be perceived as
as an evidence against the ubiquity of
life in that we you know it's it's it's
had way more than 65 million years i
mean this has been happening the early
bombardment heavy bombardment was you
know up maybe a billion years after the
formation of our solar system yeah or so
i forget and um it was you know it was
happening for there for four bit five
billion years four billion years and so
why wouldn't there be you know
tremendous colonies of
and it was co-timed with the
stromatolite you know existence and and
that we've seen and bacteria in the
oxygenation events so why not
say that the fact that you haven't seen
life on other planets or enceladus or
titan or you know
admittedly not that we have to go and
dig it up but we haven't seen any
byproducts of it so we don't have to go
there and that's like the key
feature behind what jwst is going to do
it's not going to fly to proxima
centauri b it's going to look at its
atmosphere so would you view that as a
strike in the bayesian
confidence interval sense or would you
say it just rules out panspermia as a
viable opportunity either either option
i think is is interesting right yeah but
i don't think it's either of them i
think it's something else um i i think
that in fact that that if you look at
the evidence that that we've got we
can't make that we can't make that um
that judgment because mars and venus
probably at some point in their in their
past were hospitable to earth like life
and for all we know there may well have
been um stromatolites and and and other
earth originating organisms on those
planets but we know now that neither of
those planets are hospitable to the kind
of life that evolved on earth in terms
of enceladus and and europa we haven't
actually looked you know we haven't we
haven't really looked properly there are
missions planned and we do need to and
um in that case we may well find we may
well find um you know there there will
be there will be systems um
trappist for instance probably has more
than one earth-like planet in it
and in the case like that you could ask
questions about okay what is life being
transferred between the two of them but
it's not really fair to ask that about
our solar system when the other bodies
in the solar system are pretty miserable
places to be
so another topic you know pertinent to
my astronomical audience is that
the composition of these creatures you
know some say and you talk about you
know the the laryngeal nerve of the of
the giraffe versus the the fish and you
talk about calcium in the teeth of all
these you know predators uh on earth
those fundamentally trace their
composition to a type 2 supernova
that detonated in the corner of our
galaxy that we call home um you know but
another planet a trappist system it may
not have been formed you know
identically i mean we know it's density
it's it's higher than water and less
than lead or you know you know rough
things about it but we don't know how
much calcium you know is in so if i told
you that there's no count you know
calcium is a fluke of you know saul of
our solar system you know would that
change your prior like is there any
astrophysical
connection
to a biological function that would then
be necessary for a social function
which you claim is is crucial to an
evolutionary advantage and heritability
of of the tools that would make aliens
persist and travel and so forth is there
any astrophysical link like you need
calcium and if you don't have calcium
and it's over you can't have a tongue or
i don't know i'm kind of making it up
but you wouldn't have prey predator you
know interactions without teeth in the
same way we have on earth any
astrophysical implications that we can
draw purely from astronomy on society
behavior of an alien species
i think there are some i think that
there's there are certainly some
conclusions that we can draw i don't
think that firstly i don't think that
the calcium teeth predator prey um
argument works because predators and
prey will exist
and they'll eat each other
however they manage to right you know
they'll gum each other or something like
that but and you know there were
predators long before they were teeth on
earth so um so that that's that's that's
not a problem um
i think when it comes to more
fundamental um
biochemical processes
then we have to go back and ask the
question is how
how unique how how essential is our
biochemistry right
we're fairly confident that a
carbon-based chemistry is probably
what's necessary for for for life just
because we don't know any other chemical
um
we don't know any other way of arranging
chemistry so that so that it can produce
kind of variety of
of reactions that that we see with with
organic chemistry um
beyond that you know people talk a lot
about water and the goldilocks zone uh
and you know people often forget that
non non-astronomers forget what is
really really really common in the
universe is not something rare and weird
and unique to earth
most common element a hydrogen and uh
you know fifth most common element
oxygen
so but when it comes to when it comes to
other other elements you know
i mean i think that all rocky planets
are are going to be the product of of um
supernova
it's the only way that you're going to
get you know iron and and heavy elements
like that so so
you could be right there maybe no
calcium in trappist and again this is
one of the interesting things that we're
going to find out from examining the the
atmospheric chemistry of of a lot of
these planets
but i think everyone i've spoken to um
all the sort of the the planetary
geophysicists and things like that you
know we're talking about talking about
the same rules same same laws of physics
um and and i think things are going to
be i think things are going to be pretty
similar which does not of course rule
out
the possibility of a very different
chemistry
um so for instance you know on on earth
there are
there are well nitrogen is is extremely
important in in carbon chemistry
must it be nitrogen that's important in
the in the chemistry of life on other
planets i don't know um people are
looking at other possible chemical
pathways but but um
but yeah again amino acids
uh although they sound really cool and
really indicative of life but they're
really common right you know there are
amino acids everywhere they're not
difficult things to make so it seems
reasonable that life might be based on
them
yeah our chemistry department here is
named yuri hall after the famous harold
erie who with his students uh stanley
miller did the famous miller yuri
experiment which to my knowledge hasn't
really been really functionally improved
upon i mean it's known not to represent
the earlier earth's chemistry and the
reducing atmosphere versus oxidizing
atmosphere but moving beyond that um uh
speaking of you know this book is is
particularly delightful for you know
kind of the things you throw in there
and we're talking about arc christian
batman's wonderful the zoologist guide
to the galaxy uh and uh every now and
then you'll just
you know did he just mention the brady
bunch uh yeah but i assume you're
familiar with the simpsons cartoon and
there's a famous episode where you know
like grandpa simpson tells homer simpson
if you ever go back in time never step
on anything and homer starts daydreaming
and he goes back and he steps in a bug
you die now bug you go squish
and uh and then all of all of history
has changed but you know maybe taking a
more serious role in it i always say you
know it took whales to have wi-fi in
other words like solar panels aren't
built with solar panels you know the
first operating system was written
without an operating system um you know
the first computer was designed without
a computer it's the nature of these of
these initial systems that make them so
powerful but also so random and unique
um you know we we we had this you know
kind of abundance of carbon lifeform
that made petroleum and and coal and all
sorts of things um possible and then
those were then used to power the next
generation and the next generation after
that ion drives and whatever else my
colleagues will come up warp drive um so
what to what extent is the actual path
history you know as feynman might say or
so you know like the actual path that we
took is that how flexible is it or how
resilient is it if we didn't have whales
you know we wouldn't have had you know
would have had to use something else to
have light in the oil and and so forth
um you know 200 years ago so how crucial
is or how resilient is the uh to
perturbations about the tech path that
we took to get to where we are and
beyond
and that's
a key question that's that's a crucial a
crucial question the insight that that
evolutionary biology can give to that um
is is not to answer the question
directly which we can't do because we
can't recreate uh the conditions on
early earth and run the experiment again
and and see what happens um because
clearly there were there were at the
very least there were there were
astronomical phenomena that may or may
not have happened you know the meteorite
may not have hit um earth and and and so
so things would would turn out
differently but the insight that we can
get
from evolutionary biology is to look at
ecosystem complexity
and what we can see is that for the
first two billion years of life on earth
and life lifeline is only like three and
a half billion years old for the first
two and a half billion years it was
slime it was all slime it was a very
very simple ecosystem
and then you got some simple uh
multicellular organisms
you know three and a half billion years
of life and and what we recognize as
animals and stuff like that it's only
been around for the last half billion
so so it took a long time for life to
get started but when it did and starting
about 540 million years ago
ecosystems began to become complex so
the relationships
between organisms
started to get complex complex food webs
predators prey groups you know parasites
and so on and what we've seen in the
last 540
million years has been
a dramatic increase in the complexity of
the ecosystem
particularly major event was the was the
evolution of flowering plants and then
you get insects that are pollinating the
flowers and just life exploded its life
keeps exploding into more and more and
more diversity and it seems to be
that complexity of the ecosystem that
was the basis for
our ancestors to to become to develop a
language in societies and and eventually
technology so so
no it doesn't have to be exactly the
same
but it's probably inevitable that
ecosystem complexity will increase
and if it's inevitable
ecosystem complexity will increase then
probably sooner or later yes a
technological civilization would arise
so one of the tools i used to illustrate
the lacunae in the drake equation as i
imagine saying well what if you
want to predict the number of people at
the world famous san diego zoo
here in beautiful san diego which is
normally not downpour drizzling but
normally resplendent in sunlight so i
encourage people to visit
but i say if you want to predict you
know how many people are there you can
make a kind of a drake equation and i
did it once when i was at the seti
institute in front of frank drake uh you
know kind of hostile territory and i
came up with a number and you know but i
did it without error analysis and
the error bars then come out to be plus
or minus something like two times the
number i
another negative 8 000 people or
whatever um and i was just at the san
diego zoo recently and i took my
daughter there and we saw this cop g you
know which is like this on the african
savannah they have these giant rocks and
then uh you know all these different
types of animals pretty wild diversity
of animals come there and uh and they
gather around and they're not really
sure what it is i mean you probably are
i'm not sure it is um but do you think
there's sort of a cosmic cop g you know
where where if life does exist that
we'll get together and kind of hang out
and and and talk about what we've
learned or do you do you feel more you
know less sanguine shall we say about
the prospects for you know such a thing
to exist
i've got to be i've got to be optimistic
that that again coming back to the great
filter that any civilization that can
get through the great filter
um
what are they here for right what do
they want to do okay we got through the
great filter we've solved the there's
we've fixed climate change renewable
energy and there are no more wars and
there's no more poverty and and and now
what do we do well in the star trek
universe of course we go out and explore
and and we explore in peace and and and
and and so on because what else would
you do you know
it's that essentially or in another um
science fiction trope upload your
consciousness to a computer and and and
live in this sort of artificial
artificial paradise which which i
actually think is extremely unlikely uh
to be something that that would happen
if only because
the people who would have to build this
computer into which you upload your
consciousness are scientists and
scientists is never
going to be satisfied with the
simulation because it tells them
absolutely nothing about the real world
so scientists are still going to want to
go out there and and explore and if we
can get any civilization that can get
past this great filter yes i think i
think that would be it would be uh it
would be a tremendous um
drive to create a united federation of
planets
so you talk a bit in the book about um
the differences in you know what was
called by carl sagan kind of the
universal language of math um and you
and you kind of um differ with carl um
about that and that's that's that's
great i'll leave it to the readers to
read it but um
there's one notion that you know it's
kind of interested to get your your
thoughts about which is that what if the
aliens had access to higher dimensions
um you know we we you know we don't we
believe we're superior to any kind of
flatland creature you know exist in
lower dimensions but if there are truly
higher dimensions than they're large or
they could be accessed as past guests on
the show like jim gates and and michio
kaku and others have suggested um you
know is the lack of evidence for such
creatures here i mean assuming we could
notice them and you've got to go through
a nice example of how you might notice
an alien and a higher dimension coming
here but um but the fact that we don't
see such thing could that be used in a
bayesian sense again to kind of falsify
the existence of both you know uh well
i'll just say not both higher dimensions
and higher dimensional aliens i'll just
say higher aliens that have access to
mathematical structures that we don't
have access to
well
i don't i'm i'm a zoologist i don't i
can't tell you what's the probability
that there are accessible higher
dimensions um
i i don't know but i do know that
our
laws of physics as we understand them
seem to be fairly complete we don't have
we don't understand them to the end of
course but um but they do seem to be
very consistent
so so from a bayesian perspective there
seems to be little prior reason to think
that these higher dimensions might exist
of course you may have theoretical
reasons to to think that and and i can't
argue that one i can't argue that one
with you um but one
one thing that i think is a
is a real lesson from thinking about
the mechanisms by which alien life could
evolve is that
you know i do not doubt that there will
be some really weird stuff out there i
do not doubt that there will be
somewhere in the galaxy
life forms that completely contradict
what i say in my book i i don't doubt
that at all
but i think they'll be really rare
because the obvious is common
the easy is common
and and no matter how strange and
wonderful and weird aliens might be like
they'll be the rare ones and life that
evolves in the ordinary way
in the easy way in the way that we that
we understand and and we understand that
natural selection is is a powerful force
um
you know that that that's going to be
widespread
very good uh okay eric well we've
reached now the stand uh the point in
the conversation where i'd like to ask
you audience questions if you're willing
to take some of them
um so first question
is a comment from john holly and he says
i read this book it was really cool and
insightful there we go
uh thanks for that john
the first question comes from gabe cruz
it's a little bit long but we can kind
of digest it he says differences between
human and other large mammal brains are
largely due to divergent evolution of
brain structure from a relatively recent
common ancestor this means we share
common brain hardware informed by common
sensory function
we use our sensory capability to gather
information from the same world it
appears to me that mammalian
software cognition differs more into in
co and degree
more in kind although obvious
differences are still observed in
methods i would be fascinated to hear a
discussion about the impending inter
mammalian translation of electrical
molecular brain activity how would
humans react if other species are
translated
basically if we could read the you know
dr doolittle out um you know our doc
your dog darwin over there would you do
it what would be the implications what
would be the first question you would
ask
so it's true mammalian brains share a
relatively recent
well not that reason but
certainly certainly um there's there are
a lot of uh mammals out there with with
with brains that share a relatively
recent common ancestor
brains are are ubiquitous all animals
have brains because all animals need to
translate the sensory information into
mostly into into decisions and into
motor movements
but brains have really really really
expensive organs they use an awful lot
of energy they're easily damaged um and
so no animal has a brain more complex
than it needs
and that means that all of these
mammal brains which may look very
similar to us in terms of hardware
but their software is there to perform
the tasks they need to perform not
perform the tasks we need to perform
so if you think about um if you think
about dogs or dolphins or anything else
you know they've got a brain that they
need and it and it performs the tasks
that they need and
specifically one of the tasks it doesn't
perform or so we believe
until we prove otherwise is language
so we as um
very complex social primates need
language is absolutely essential in our
in our evolutionary past when we lived
in in large groups of of competing um
competing hominins that we had this way
of communicating way of passing
information way of understanding each
other and
animals that don't live in those groups
don't need that so even if it's built
upon the same hardware they don't have
the software it's just not necessary so
it's unreasonable to think
that you could invent a machine that
would read a dog's brain
and make it something that we could
understand this is the famous
wittgenstein quote right if a lion could
talk we wouldn't understand it not
because
of any of any limitations but only
because that
that experience that they have
isn't translatable
to a human experience
um so so yes there are similarities of
course they are we are built we've got
the same four legs we've got the four
limbs we've got the same bilateral
symmetry
as our ancestors did
but the software's different
yeah on that topic i called david
chalmers i'm working on a pseudonymously
written book
called what is it like to be thomas
nagle by
a period bat
uh staying with the brain uh philos uh
question a very kind of meandering
question by listener uh viewer ms
and it has to do with maybe chiral
asymmetry um but also in the fundamental
split between the halves of the brain
and uh this lit you know commenter says
it's unknown
why we have two halves of the brain of
course most why questions aren't really
answerable in the domain of physics you
know without some teleological purpose
but um what about the uh the asymmetry
is there an asymmetry in the properties
function
role of the hemispheres of other mammals
or other animals even
i think it's i think um although it's
not my field but i put my stick my neck
out and say i think it's fairly clear
why we have two hemispheres
of the brain the same reason we have two
eyes and and you know we're bilaterally
symmetrical um and this is this is a
fundamental property of almost all
animals um on earth and and i believe on
other planets too it's it's just our
ancestors and we're now going back a
very very long way so we're going right
back into into before before we have any
fossils billion years ago
our ancestors were bilaterally
symmetrical because
it just provided such a tremendous
movement advantage and once you are you
once you have that physical structure
then remember evolution builds on what
you've got it doesn't invent things new
so everything that we've built on top of
that since then has inherited that that
structure been been constrained by the
structure so i'm not surprised that that
the brain um
that the brain has two has two
hemispheres are there any
interesting
spontaneous breaking of symmetry that we
see in in biology in the same way as we
see for instance in chirality of of of
certain molecules um
there is
you know there are
events in there are evolutionary events
that that could have gone one way or the
other and happened to go one way right
and and and then you're stuck with that
um
mostly we illustrate that with with
really maladaptive things like for
instance uh the laryngeal nerve that the
the the the giraffe has to go all the
way down the neck and all the way back
up again just because
it's inherited um it's inherited what it
was was stuck with
but um
but i think none of them none of them
really
none of them really shape the the the
the future of evolution in the same way
that that biochemical chirality doesn't
or the balance between matter and
antimatter doesn't
right you know there's no difference
we might be made of antimatter living
you know in an antimatter universe it's
just a name there's more of one kind
than there is of the other so that that
spontaneous breaking of symmetry
oftentimes doesn't actually have have
visible effects
no there's an old joke just getting back
to the giraffe you know giraffe seems to
be you know this this magical creature i
mean uh you wouldn't really expect such
a such an animal to exist and then uh
you know it's like people that say well
what what are like sean carroll like
what are all the purposes of all these
galaxies in the hubble deep field you
know uh why should it be that way and if
i were god i wouldn't make it and you
know one of my rabbi friends says you
know what i would be doing right now if
i were god
the same thing god's doing right now you
think i know better than god you know i
think like to say that oh well you know
another giraffe on an exoplanet might
not have its laryngeal nerve make a four
meter journey uh i think it's a little
bit uh you know kind of like discounting
the the effectiveness of the of the of
the engineering solution that whatever
god or nature engineered but i don't
want to get too far down that that
particular uh rabbit hole
um i do want to ask uh just a cure are
you a vegetarian or what fraction of
zoologists are vegetarians
i am and it's it's it's quite high it's
not not ubiquitous but but it's pretty
high and um
and yeah that shouldn't surprise you
and what fraction of zoologist are uh
theologically inclined or theistically
inclined shall i say um
i think that zoologists and
i
imagine
other scientists as well but but
speaking to the people i know tend um
not to be combative about subjects like
this so except for one in particular
yes okay and there are always um there
are always exceptions but but um on the
other hand there are um a number of
theistic uh of quite prominent theories
so the obvious simon conway morris of
course
very famous robert asher is another
member of our department who also is it
so it's it's um it's not an uncommon
it's not an uncommon position to hold
but um
but you know we have the we have the
advantage that that we are
we are confident with our with our
understanding of how life could have
evolved so so as as long as um a
religious or a theistic zoologist
understands that and they do because
otherwise they wouldn't be a zoologist
then there's really no threat
no one's sort of threatening anyone else
i suppose if you were a geologist
and someone can say well you know i
believe the world was created in in six
days you might you might say but that
undermines everything that
that i believe but uh but as long as a
theistic um as long as a theistic
zoologist understands evolution then
there's no real threat
very good okay back to it just two more
audience questions and then we'll close
out um
so uh
the question this is kind of a
tongue-in-cheek maybe perhaps or maybe
some other body part in cheek but um
a commenter by the name of lv
gamer cats
um
cats which i chose almost chose for one
of my kids names
but he or she asks is the 20
21 second law of
urinating uh is that universal if in
other words how might it differ if
mammals evolved in a planet with half
the gravity of earth or twice the
gravity of earth uh sort of these bodily
functions and maybe just globally
speaking no pun intended but what would
be the implications are there physical
limitations to the existence of
intelligent
you know uh sentient uh organisms uh in
other words the gravity is a thousand
you know you're on a proto-black hole is
that going to happen
so uh you'll have to forgive me that i'm
not familiar with the 22nd one 21 second
rule of urination um
yeah but
and there are and there will be of
course um and
the
as i talk about in in in the first part
of my book yeah the physics does
constrain because if you live on a
planet with with a very thin atmosphere
you're not going to communicate with
sound you know if you live on a planet
with an opaque atmosphere you're not
going to communicate with with light
there are some things that are that
that are clearly dictated by um
by the laws of physics
gravity is one that science fiction
authors tend to enjoy playing about with
but you know
it's a and no doubt there is you know
there's there's an issue here and
there's an issue about flight and how
you might fly and what what might be
buoyant and what might not be there's
all kinds of all kinds of interesting
questions you could explore but they're
purely speculative until we know the
details of a planet
but one thing that's important to
remember though is that
is that
if you take these physical uh conditions
to the extreme the problem is no longer
biological becomes chemical
so if you were to uh live on the surface
of a
of a white dwarf something like that and
and or live on the surface of neutron
stars famous science fiction story about
um life on the surface of a neutron star
then the question is what chemical
reactions could take place would
molecules be stable
under those under those conditions and
so i think it's i think
you know physics is very low level and i
think the effects are primarily going to
be felt at the low level
to hear eric's answers to the thrilling
three
please subscribe to brian's mailing list
at
forward slash list
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed that episode cruising
through the galaxy along with the
renowned zoologist dr eric hershamoon i
did and i know if you loved this video
you're gonna enjoy this special playlist
which i've created just for you contains
some of my greatest hits on the search
for extraterrestrial life in the
universe the prospects for fabricating
life in the laboratory and so much more
please click here for that special
playlist i curated just for you don't
forget to give this video a thumbs up
and leave a comment in the section below